[Music]
all right welcome back to careful boys
it's off the record and today we're
doing something a little different so we
usually do this ask the boys on patreon
but we just wanted to give you a little
taste of what we do on patreon so if you
want to check it out you go ahead and
check it out in the link in the
description box below we got the patreon
exclusive stuff just like this and ask
the boys is we go on instagram and we
say yo we got some questions you guys
want some life
experience talks all this stuff our
personal stuff
ask us right here you could personally
get these answered on video and we do it
on patreon but we're gonna do it here on
youtube today special time what a treat
yeah it's great and everybody asks the
weirdest questions that's not bad when
you guys send really funny questions but
um what i want to do right now is i
really want to answer this sincere
question from angel muns
thank you angel muntz thank you angela
it's it's one of those good ones good
ones from angel buns oh that's a good
one what do you think how do i find love
isn't that so nice that someone would
just like really ask that first off i'd
be like
you lonely you're so lonely oh my god
how long have you been single yeah
what i lose everybody laugh at her face
go you're such a loser oh my god you're
so lonely nobody loves you okay
real good question i got that out of my
system yeah yeah you know what the heck
you answer is the view answer
it also kind of works like you before
you can love anyone else you have to
love yourself
[Applause]
i mean that's so true though right
that's really true for real though
honestly that's kind of true though
no it's really true tell me about your
experience well
you really can't like offer somebody
like your full 100
if you're not 100 you you know and if
you're
not complete and you're with somebody
else
it's just giving them like 50 of you and
that's not really love because they
can't even receive that love from you
you can't receive that love for yourself
so that's true it's very true you're
that british comedian he was [ __ ] i
forgot his name but on his honesty
jimmy carr no no he's his stand-up
special right
uh ricky gervais oh i think he's him no
no he did a whole love special
it was about relationships and
the guy that was just like oh like it's
that one that everyone breaks up
afterwards yeah yeah yeah that one i
don't know that i don't look at his name
he has a quote in there and i'm a
butcher this right a lot of [ __ ]
facts misusing right now but but it's
along the lines of we live our lives
like
trying to hire people to fill the void
and the love that we don't have and a
lot of people do that right they get
into relationships and they don't love
themselves they don't
they're they're searching for this thing
called love and then they try they try
to get with the person that will fill
that void because they don't know how to
do that themselves and then so now
you're like putting all of your uh that
love responsibility on your partner and
it's not fair to them because they're
like yo make me happy make me happy fix
me or even even putting your self-esteem
on your partner too yeah you don't make
me feel good yeah yeah you don't make me
feel confident
you don't hide me that's a that's a
that's true even though it's funny like
it's like yeah dude how do you love
yourself and find all of that before you
go out into the dating world and find a
relationship yeah that's i think that's
it's a reverse thing because people go i
gotta find love so then they go try to
hit on girls go on dates whatever and
then they finally get into a
relationship and they're like oh i found
love versus like are you cool with who
you are
because i think we're all [ __ ] up in
our own weird ways right like everyone
individually is just kind of they're in
their own head like whatever your issues
are i feel like a lot of times
especially when you're young you don't
really know what those issues are and
you have to kind of spend some time with
yourself and
you don't even know you have issues
exactly like you yeah so you i think you
have to
spend time with yourself a little bit
and kind of understand that because when
you get in a relationship with other
people
uh those issues can be
shown and exacerbated with in
relationships because relationships are
really hard in general i was going to
say though to that point like i feel
like relationships or dating different
kinds of people
like lets you figure that out yeah it's
not as apparent if it's just you because
it's true then it's like it's pretty
easy for me at least it's pretty easy to
excuse habits and things that i do by
myself because i'm like oh this doesn't
affect x y and z person but when it at
least for me when it starts affecting
other people i'm like oh these are all
things that are negatively impacting
other people's lives and i can do
something about it so i should like work
on that not saying that like you should
go into a relationship looking to like
you know troubleshoot your own life but
it does have a way of like
highlighting certain things that it's
like oh like i should work on that oh
and also
like the person that you you're with
like actually enjoy them yeah like like
them like not just love like you can
love someone but you can love someone
from afar that's true
actually like being with enjoy their
company and stuff because you can love
family members but not like them exactly
the same thing because in a relationship
we see this all the [ __ ] time where
people fall out of like like they might
love them and care for them but they're
like i [ __ ] hate hanging out with you
you're so goddamn annoying and i think
that happens a lot it's my mom
i love her
i don't know if i like you very much
but that's so true though the point that
you did though it doesn't sound like it
wasn't was there a point that you did
though doesn't sound like it it sounds
like it's it's a different relationship
i think i did up until i'm like damn
this [ __ ] is [ __ ] great
bro what at what point when she sent you
to temple were you like oh this is weird
do you remember that moment the moment
that fashion was crazy the turning point
that you went i actually don't like my
mom i think like seven or eight wow
dang that's pretty young yeah because i
think when you start hanging out in
other people's homes yeah and you start
seeing other moms found the dream mom
that you wanted
dream mom wait no one else does the [ __ ]
you do i noticed that hmm
here here's another good question right
here but from uh keaney leo i like your
question this is a good one
does a male have to be dominant while
having sex with a female what
it depends on
yeah it's like whatever that's your
business like it's like whatever works
for you and your partner for me it has
to be it has to be always one percent
more dominant so if like she's writing
me hard what i'll do is i'll i'll take
one of the fingers i'll just i'll just
bend it okay okay
just something
that's hilarious maybe the proper
phrasing would be like
do women expect that oh okay i think
that's a better place
like as in like do do men have to isn't
is that something that women want more
often also we need a woman's answer it's
definitely a spectrum
it depends on like who you are and what
you like yeah okay yeah because a lot of
women are like oh i love to be dominant
but then a lot of them are also like oh
i want to be submissive um ask your
partner
communication that's the key right there
can you don't make the decision until
you've efficiently gauged what someone
else likes i think it's um when i was
younger i thought very black and white
where it's like do all women like this
well like i would ask questions like you
could say do only like only black and
white guys
[Laughter]
just like there's nowhere on this pie
for me what about yellow what about
asian no no but like
we think in dualities right when you're
younger you think like oh all girls do
this because you hear that you hear it
because it's simplistic thinking and
you're [ __ ] 16 years old right but
then you start to realize no like there
might be some general truths but you
have to interview the person you're with
100 and then work with them and talk
about it there might be some women out
there that are like i'm just super
nurturing and i just you know i love it
when a guy is just like you know
a complete [ __ ] sip yeah i don't know
maybe for sure i'm sure
i feel like you would be like
okay
sip in bed you know what i mean i'm just
like please stop i don't have something
like that like what do you mean
like no please i don't want to say that
or like she's trying to sex me and i'm
like i'm tired i hit her with me
that's not a sin
what do you mean what do you mean what
do you mean by
he's like please can i hang your [ __ ]
please
like a guy who just like reverts to
becoming like a slave to the girls like
wishes ooh honey what do you want me to
do honey return to a simple male mind of
like i want to just
appease you
twice says it i'm like [ __ ] i think i am
it's a compliment to a woman when she
makes you simp and you're normally not
like that yeah
yeah bro because i'm [ __ ] super good
men in the street sipping the sheets
[ __ ] tough i am dude i'm super tough
i think it's a compliment whenever you
are able to tell a girl like hey you're
making me do something i don't normally
do and i just want 100
women like that when you do you tell
them your vulnerabilities you're like
there's like a special bond between you
two yeah because she doesn't want to
hear that it's all the same [ __ ] like oh
you think i'm hot you like i'm always
sipping and you're just vacuuming the
floor
i exclusively clean the house bro
i am a simple [ __ ]
but you're also a one-woman man which is
like we can't measure up to that if you
have to choose one
you did it right
here's a that brings us to alice owens
question um she asked how
to not be a psycho when you're getting
rejected
but if she's being really honest and
open about that i i really respect that
i i respect that
don't take it personally i think the
core there are other people in the world
there's the core of the i mean the the
answer here is just self-discipline
right first of all take a breath
take a deep breath you gotta hit him
with i didn't like you anyway you're a
loser today's video is brought to you by
audible
you know what i realized
my parents are stupid okay and so i'm
like man my parents are so stupid that's
what i'm so stupid
and i don't know [ __ ] you go to school
and you can't apply that so i'm like mad
school stupid and so these days i got
wrong kinds of problems you know in
relationships in the business and
everything i'm like how can i improve
myself and that's why i really like
audiobooks because it's very convenient
for a way to improve your life have
self-awareness and like progress
yourself and these days i've been
listening to extreme ownership by jocko
willink and he takes all these really
cool war stories and he pretty much says
in one sentence
it's all your fault um i love that yeah
like even if even if the circumstances
you can't predict them [ __ ]
bombing you and [ __ ] you know what it's
your fault it's your fault because you
gotta figure out what to do with it and
in some ways i like that because it kind
of takes your life your you take control
back of your own life i also learned
that um i am an audio learner really not
much of a reader because my mind drifts
away and um it's a little bit harder
because i think i absorb sound a little
bit better when i listen to someone i'm
more focused i lock in so i started
listening to audio books much more than
actually reading books because have you
ever like bought a book and then you
like you read chapter one you're like
man this this book is so good but it
takes so much focus because you have to
sit there and like a lot time for it but
it's much easier like on the go like on
a long drive whatever to listen to it so
this is why i love audible but here's
the other thing it doesn't have to be
about like all this serious stuff it
doesn't have to be like self-help stuff
they have so many things thousands of
titles to choose from they have comedy
they have podcasts they have so many
different things to go for so definitely
check them out yeah so if all this
interests you whether you want to grow
or laugh or just be entertained go to
audible.com off the record or text off
the record to 500 500 go to audible.com
off the record or text off the record to
500 500 and learn some [ __ ] so you're
not so stupid yeah but don't take it
like this
[Laughter]
i think it's fair to say we've all
you know served our time in being a
little bit psycho right
just me i'm the [ __ ] weirdo we all
have we all have but it's it's it's a
funny question because it's like how do
i not kill somebody for telling me i
don't want i've been oh yeah well that's
a different yeah hopefully she doesn't
mean that exciting she probably wouldn't
see me by psycho we're just gonna have
to imagine that uh psycho just means
highly rather really easy fix on how to
help how to calm your mind and i think
it's a long term
process of that's why everyone's getting
into mindfulness therapy meditation
because all these techniques really do
work maybe some therapy oh yeah maybe
something
professional advice not from people like
us
right don't ask the internet about it
one thing that i do i will always say uh
because like i started out like super
[ __ ] jealous dude like what did you
do you used to beat your girlfriends let
me know the truth
i think i think i had a complex with
wanting to be wanted all the time and
confirmed that hey you still want me
like i'll check every day yeah it's
[ __ ] annoying and that is psycho and
i think that like the only thing i could
really do is like always say i'll do
better next time like i [ __ ] this up i
deserve to lose it i'll do better next
time so i think in in your case alice if
you feel like you're going psycho with
someone just know that that means you're
just not a pro at it yet you'll do
better next week when did you
get to the point where you're like oh i
can
let my girls hang out with anyone they
want to without me thinking that they're
trying to bone everybody i think the key
really is to just look at yourself like
uh i spent so much time judging someone
else that you know i didn't take the
time to look at me and go like who [ __ ]
am i you know like that's my main
default now is anytime that i felt like
i was being judgmental over who i was
dating i was like well who the [ __ ] am i
first yeah
yeah you are bro what's wrong with me so
then you are you know that just puts you
in a place that you can't really like
persecute yourself
because
you got cheated on before or just you
started imagining [ __ ] i think it's just
a complex you know like different
different kids getting different
complexes from growing up certain ways
and i think like i was always never sure
if my parents really liked me oh
manifested in women yeah because of that
i was it's like you said you you try to
fill the void that you've had growing up
outside your relationships and so when
you seek that in a partner it's like
it's not their job bro
like you're supposed to be whole already
before you start seeking a partnership
so maybe she has a huge issue with
rejection yeah like something in her
childhood is like hey nah man
[ __ ] what
you said no
yeah well then obviously that means
maybe alice's mind is going in a state
of desperation at times where it doesn't
need to but again you only get better
that with experience all i can say is if
you are losing something because you're
a psycho you honestly deserve to lose it
that's the best way to learn
that's true yeah like let it go man yeah
and i know there's a lot of cases where
they probably like probably gave you a
chance and loved you but then like you
scared them away
yeah well scared them away to put it on
it's all your fault
who has the weirdest fetish
that's great
we'll determine that after we each share
what do you think my fetish is i'm
pretty vanilla muay thai shorts i think
nick's fetish is
bart docking nick's booty hole while
they're in battle
that's oddly specific
yeah nick is the sniper yeah yeah and
he's on top of me do any of you guys
actually have real fetishes that you
actually think are weird nah mine's
normal i like fun i like lingerie and i
like white oh white
white white white lingerie
that's like
everything
aryan people
why lingerie's hot yeah i like lingerie
too but it's very it's very vanilla and
i like business suits
what about a chick in lingerie with a
business suit over it oh i like the real
estate and she pops the buttons off her
realtor
i like that one the realtor business
suits and it's low apr you mean like
women with the with the pinstripe slacks
in the whole suit and in the shoulder
[ __ ] the shoulder pads the shoulder
pads on their blazers like the uh
shoulder pads get you going crazy like
uh like like a law firm like cia movies
right where the chicks are like you know
going around and [ __ ]
that's hot that's what the librarian
look right they look like all dressed up
like yeah or or you know john wick
and john wick where he there you see the
behind the scenes of the continental
hotel the operators and all the chicks
are like oh yeah yeah yeah okay yeah
everyone looks like a librarian but with
tattoos but they're all like tatted up
yeah
what about you yeah what's your weird
face i'm pretty vanilla dude i'm pretty
vanilla like
yeah we talk about [ __ ] nutrition all
the time while we're having sex
honestly it's a weird fetish actually
i just like spending time like being
physically intimate with my girl simp
i just like i just like i like physical
touch crown by sway bro she nailed it
dude yeah well just like i just can we
just tickle each other and [ __ ]
cuddle no that's not what do you mean
so not even [ __ ] just just being
naked and just saving all the like
normal [ __ ] yeah i like having my
penis inside a vagina yeah i like having
penises out of a vagina i like a lot of
kissing i like a lot of
kisser yeah i like kissing you're
romantic folks okay how about this let
me let me let me uh let me i'm gonna
find it for you okay when it's not
sexual what is something that that'll
trigger your mind that maybe your girl
does
out of the bedroom well it's not sexual
everything is sexual well like for
instance for me like something that
really stands out to me that's not
necessarily sexual is like when a girl
is 90 degrees flexible and she bends
down to talk to me like this oh really
she can see her cleavage that's sexual i
don't have to see any part of it it's
just when girls talk to you like that
when you're like sitting in a [ __ ]
like stewardess or like a waitress yeah
and you're just like take all my tip
money but i've always liked that thing
and it doesn't mean that like i
conservative fetish because i'm like
that's unusual you're gonna be horny in
japan specifically yeah
don't have anything that like like that
particular i can think of i like when my
girl looks really beautiful like i like
when she dresses
i like she dresses up
such a romantic [ __ ] she dresses up
because she dresses to the t bro like
she she's she's the sweet she's the
fashionista
you are so when she dresses up and she
has like certain dresses that i really
think are pretty fine i i get your boy
he's like
dude you're the best [ __ ] guy no bro
i'm just being nah i'm just i'm just
boring bro i think
sometimes i wish hannah wasn't such a
top
such a tall girl because i want to grab
her by the back of her shirt like this
in the back of her belt and throw her on
a bed like that but my weak ass can't
[ __ ] do it
i like lifting up my girl i like doing
that so do you like go for the work
you're helping him find more stuff yeah
we don't i don't throw her around
you gotta you gotta work on the [ __ ]
deadlift i wanna use her as a [ __ ]
battering ram and slam my double doors
inside of my my room and just slam it
through and and then toss her to the bed
and she'll land with her [ __ ] pants
dropping i'll run over and [ __ ] dive
and start boning her dude like this
jazz being kicked out of fresh prince
house exactly right but my fantasy will
never become real because she's way
taller never said never that's why you
gotta go i gotta get like bark you know
like [ __ ] get buffed yeah yeah
the key to your fantasy is to get more
like
i'll get the new leather lingerie just
have bart do it and then you just come
with it
carl will do it and then joe will be on
his back you'll be like yeah this is the
horse thank man way of doing it bro and
then and then once she gets the throwing
down bart leaves he's like all right or
or wow bart throws her on the bed and
then joe come on throws you on top
[Laughter]
while you're stuck behind his back yeah
i had a friend who uh she said one of
her like sexual fantasies was that and
no one had ever done this to her because
she didn't know how to bring it up but
she her fantasy is that she's getting uh
having sex
she's getting done doggy and then
the dude leaves switches with another
guy and then the original dude appears
across the yard in another house in a
different window just watching dude that
is so elaborate holy [ __ ] he does this
but she goes that would be the hottest
thing that means the windows have to
line up too i know it takes a lot of
architecture
the setting has to be perfect so like
she wants what she wants she wants the
exactly it's the feeling of being
pranked like very like obscenely oh so
she loves prank concepts
okay like hey what about here okay so
thoughts thoughts to make this less
convoluted so you instead of involving
another person just record yourself get
a big ass tv on the other side that way
you could be hitting it from behind and
then just hit play that's why you worked
in [ __ ] showbiz
yeah do you guys like me watch depends
on who if it's my mom probably not if
it's an a game day maybe
if i'll
you like being watched um yeah really i
think that's hot you'd be you you should
make only fans then like that would have
been my career
[Laughter]
what do you mean being watched like like
let's say uh the 20th floor of a hotel
they can't see who you are like [ __ ]
in public they're oh i say
is strangers more alluring or like keep
friends or no strangers
friends and family what about at the
family come over for a watch party
co-workers
what about the fountain at the mall like
what about like is there a place like
the forest or like ikea or like the holy
grail place to do it
and is it is it like being watched or
the fear of getting caught you're
getting caught so then you don't want
people watching but it's the it's the
danger of potentially but like if you're
watching might be huh that's that's part
of the thing yeah
i only want girls to watch me all right
a lot more guys want girls to watch uh
because if i'm like if i have an
audience you know and i'm like yeah
right and then there's a guy that's like
i'm like
stop well yeah there's this like place
in vegas i think it's vegas it's called
like the green no green door green door
i mean what
who said that
what is that
i like went there
and it was just like a whole bunch of
guys watching it wasn't even fun what
screen door what's green door don't they
have a rule that you have to come as a
couple no oh see that [ __ ] everything
up exactly and are they beating off
together yes in a [ __ ] circle it's
weird so it's a real circle jerk yes
well they messed up on the ratio and
were they looking over to you and you're
like i'm not one nope
i walked right off
you see dudes touching themselves yeah
do they do they all do this together
do you see a beat while chanting it's a
that
satanic
performer that looks like five guys but
it's all pipes connected with clothes
doing it
oh my god
he's in there it was fun oh it's one guy
yeah the ratios are still fine
i don't know that i have like a crazy
kink or anything like that i think
most of the porn that i end up watching
is like stuff that like doesn't feel
produced like the new ronin gear like
[ __ ] yeah amateur yeah that's always
better i don't know because i found
myself laughing how much it's important
i'm just like
what are you doing yeah nobody [ __ ]
like this like some guy like just
stumbles in the room like oh no my dicks
are like where did this guy come so
nobody here has like king kings not
really what would you consider like a
kinky like like i like somebody smacking
my butt with a whip like foot fetish or
something like that no i like twitter
actually i like tan lines i think yeah
oh that's nice
that's a good one i can't explain it
either i don't know where that comes
from you like that you like the one from
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
i love snorkel tans
[Music]
you